on may 10 2012 film courage attended a
press roundtable interview with Chazz
Palminteri for the film mighty fine
written and directed by Debbie Goodstein
this audio contains a full interview
from that press day for more information
on mighty fine which opens in theaters
Friday May twenty-fifth please visit
mighty fine hyphen a movie com still
have to drum up work for your career and
you know you're just stuff just
continues well you know because I'm a
writer and a director too besides being
an actor that I'm always working mm-hmm
seems like I'm always working which is
good so work but gets out of work yes
and when I'm not acting I'm ready you
know looking for something to direct so
movies I'm always writing always right
that's important I'm very fortunate that
I don't have to sit around and wait like
an actor for a part you know I right by
your part which is good sometimes she's
really good i just wrote a good play for
Broadway cool that just got option for
probably called human and i'll play that
part you know and i'll write the
screenplay for the movie in oakland i
don't know if i'll play that but I just
directed put some instant we'll see how
many plays have you written uh faithful
bronze tail dog day for and they all did
on Broadway or have they all been no a
farm but they all been performed yes and
thankful was just done out here in fact
faithful has been better like 15
countries Brock Steele is being I just
at bronx tale in vegas the one-man show
it's nice being done for in Paris
someone's doing it there someone else is
playing you yes I was the first time I
let somebody do that there was a forgot
his name Francois a very famous for a
jockey kept calling me please i want to
do it and I said you know he's there yet
another language so good dude he a trans
Franken yeah I think this is nice thing
yes I think that might be his last
inning that he's doing in Paris up till
June have you seen it no no I couldn't
have just been busy cuz i was wondering
if you felt like he was like you but no
be like me doing it his way his you know
which is right I said don't try to do
what I did do it you're away in your
language know when he's doing my script
you know I'm sure he's massaging isn't
changing its funny I have a question
about this particular performance yes
you had to blow up so many times did
that affect you when you had to get
upset like that no at all no no I cuz I
you know I have a tennis ignores an
actor I can go from zero to 60 right
away some actors can't do that something
you know some can I'm one of those
actors you can do you know I never lose
my temper of a very calm guy but I
haven't but I but I can have a bad
temper if I lose it so I never lose it
so it's always there see so what the
chance that i let out is when i do a
roll so it's gonna spit there it gets
rid of that for you it's ready yeah okay
you mentioned in the press notes that
you did research about people who have
survived abusive homes and that there's
a through line of anger personalities
what research did you do yeah well one
is still I spoke to debbie about her dad
that was the main 1i asked about a
father how was he samedi father act in
this situation would your father do here
and then I took liberties and then I
spoke to some people who were
manic-depressives who were in therapy
and I asked him well what made you
realize that you finally needed help and
you know you can see that they just
could not control themselves that they
when they thought they were going to hit
their kids and they did hit the kid that
they knew they had to give up they had
to get home but here's a guy in the 70s
very proud guy who's back then no what
talking about getting home even people
today don't talk about it sometimes you
know it's a you know anger anger is
something that's like giving you dying
of cancer I guess I angry these loses
his temper he's fine you know don't know
he's a great guy Plus now here here was
a a Jewish woman who survived the
Holocaust who looked at him like he was
god she's not going to say
so it was like the perfect storm was
terrible well given that dual nature of
the character and how he's so
charismatic and such a charmer on one
side know that the rest of the world
doesn't see is it almost like
approaching like almost like two roles
and bringing them together it's two
people yes yes that's what made him so
dangerous he was so charming and so what
the filth of the kids but then all of a
sudden he would just turn on a dime I
mean those guys is horrible so so those
people people who are like that turn on
a dime and they just switch I mean I
know people like that I know a wise guy
like that he was scared at least a few
questions a mirage of questioning acted
actually actually because I was telling
the lady was a teenager when you came
out with Bronx tell yes when we finally
chose to Joe's to making it to a
filament and and it's a bit of a relief
to see in person and to hear how you
talk and your demeanor and that sort of
thing to distinguish the wise guy the
owner says intelligent young dings well
taking all this according to IMDb oh I
got to read this because it really
sparked a couple things I'm sure which
one of your writers roids as Chaz
Palminteri was a natural choice to
continue the italianate torch in film in
the tradition of Martin Scorsese De Niro
about four feet taller than pacino them
right but I was pretty credible actor
amazing he's amazed that he was in the
active studio when he was ten years he
was in the class 10 years ahead of him
you know he's a wonderful actor in our
view you went from the hood number two
would yes right I don't wait to hear it
I beg playing the leading role yeah did
you ever imagine that would be the case
when you first took on yes you did you
know us yes this you know I know that
sounds a little sorry that sounds people
who has asked me did you ever think we
would get this foreign language go yes
you know that's good yeah I had a mother
father would credibly support him always
told me that I would make it I think
that's what did it have incredible
amount of confidence and someone like my
parents i'll take a very quick story
that when i was actor striving to make a
living and I was working as a bouncer in
Manhattan I would come home really late
I would write our little index card his
dad I meet 20 bucks and I was slipping
under their doors they live on the
apartment above and I'm the bun
department of Nathan and I did that for
about six months and then finally I
started getting a job and I started
working and I forgot about it and cut to
20 something years later 24 years later
I got nominated for Academy Award for
bullets over Broadway and I told my
parents that I wanted to walk down the
red carpet with me because they
supported me all these years and I was
with my wife and me in the limo and my
parents were there just before I got out
to promote pocket my parent I father
reached into his pocket and said here we
got this ready to save this dream I said
was that a ticketing open up his card of
this soap envelope I see all these index
cards and I see I said wait a minute I
said that's my handwriting what is that
he's not sure another 25 years ago he
had nobody said mean your mother we save
those cards because we knew this day
would come that's here
interesting I was pretty heavy doing
save those cards that when this baby
comes that's that's pretty believe yeah
that's the time runs out yeah yes good I
was first of all very honored to be here
fathers readiness to thank ya thank you
and i'm fining from examiner so secondly
there's a movie that I saw a few years
back it was starring Dustin Hoffman I
came up already but the show movie it
was Barney's Version yes and it's about
a man who has used I heard about it.c
and in your character in this from what
I understand is also because I didn't
see a difference no he's not all timers
he's more bipolar this is what yours
anger issues okay so it's not know
there's a mental disorder that's good
yes it's neurological army yes now anger
issues it is a mental disorder yeah
absolutely what is it seems like a judo
is partly chemical but then it's also
partly that his status is slipping and
he's very frustrating about that you
know what happens with people who are
people who are the automatic depresses
the funny thing about them is they can
handle when things are going great man
and that like high as a kite but the
essence of what mental health is is how
you handle adversity and he just can't
do it just once the image is broken and
losing my money and I can't be Joe find
any more I can't be this guy or
everybody loves they can't how did you
research for this throne well I spoke to
the director who that was based on a dad
and I spoke to I've met people who were
manic-depressives and I have spoke to
psychiatrist who was told me about manic
depressive I was in therapy myself you
know so that helped me you know i was
never bought a depressive mai fact I
wanted to Darby for because i knew i was
going to be famous soon so I thought I'm
getting ahead of my bicep me you're
coming here I said here doc I'm going to
bust
day now because I was I did the play and
I got it got sold but then he avoided
and I knew it was gonna be a big movie
and I said I just want to get ahead of
this whole thing that he said I never
got anybody not practical but ok let's
talk and you know what there were some
issues that i did have to work out so
work out ok so along the side of the
mental health well component this
component of this i see that in a red
that you have quite an affinity for the
family unit and you have your philosophy
on raising children oh and you have you
know quite a bit of you you pretty much
dictate that anything that goes around
in the family unit will pretty much man
fences that's yeah exactly i mean the
you know I really my father was my
father's little said the saddest thing
in life is wasted talent he's known as
said that I I wrote it but he's not have
said it to me and I wrote those words
you know the family is very very
important to me because the world is so
hard out there and tough you got to have
the Oasis the fan are there we got to
keep together with my children and my
wife I mean am i perfect know if I might
work in progress yes nobody's perfect
nobody so everybody's issues that so the
tie into mighty fine the time will you
go grab the gun and this do you think
that you would ever done up to that
place no really no some of us can
identify with possibly I could
understand that but I know myself in my
heart I could I make it real on the
screen yes but in my heart I would never
do that that spoke volumes I couldn't do
that because any memory that you do or
anything that you say is your child's
memory for life you can't take it back
like I didn't mean that I'm sorry so I
always tell people that when I talk to
when I give a lecture on something I
always talk about a fam about being a
parent that anything you say anything
you do is that child's memory for life
look I was sitting on a stoop I was 10
years old and this man killed the man
from here from where you are right in
front of me and I just was like and then
he kind of turned to me and looked at me
and I could sell you i can tell you felt
bad that he walked
and then my dad Grammy about my almond
drinking upstairs so that was my early
memory of what anger could do I thought
they were fighting over a parking space
I didn't to me I still thought it was a
parking space so till this day you know
it's how do you use the experiences in
life make you what you are till this day
will find a front parking and a guy
jumps in my space I want to go because I
have a temper I want to go you I've done
it and I just say it's cool and pull out
I let it go because I saw what could
happen over nothing now I found out
later it wasn't open nothing I still
don't know why but anything had happened
so you got to keep really one of the
scenes in the Bronx don't that I
remember yeah when you lose your
temporary life the only thing that could
happen to something bad even if you're
right you're wrong my father used to say
that you lose your temper even if you're
right you're wrong if you're drunk if
you're right you roll but how do you
balance that from being a doormat to
allowing people like you know with
Estella she was always placating
gentlemen she made him a god and he
needed that give all my god Oh jump to
your father's dizzy father's dead
because she was a Holocaust about it so
she just enabled him to be the way he
was you see should see it sounds so
that's what made it so interesting the
25th yeah so she just enabled him going
back to your intuition and your family's
intuition that you would cross over
where so many actors don't do you think
people should give a timeline a deadline
what if somebody comes here from another
state do they give themselves X amount
of years to quote make it or do they
continue along here only job that's a
good question I always say the people
who always said you know I have
something to fall back on then pull back
on it I had nothing before background it
was he I do I was gonna make it I cannot
explain them I don't want to come off as
some pompous person but I knew in my
heart of ha
that I was going to make people said
well how do you feel when you met the
narrow I said feel good I felt they said
how do you feel when you first started
acting when I went I felt like I was
where I'm supposed to be I know that's
incredibly it's not arrogant it was just
self-confidence I have that confidence
and I think that's from my parents who
just kept saying you are good you're
great you can do this and you know how
were you when you first decided that's
what you I want to be an active probably
1001 yes I used to imitate the guys on
the corner I said that I want to do this
you know then I saw a movement i got
although I thought will be called which
is still my favorite movie called on the
waterfront llevala Brandon when I never
forgot that and I always said I could do
that I want to try that I could do that
you know and I always had a voice in my
head saying that I could do that and I'm
gonna do that you know I always said I'm
gonna do that I was broke I said I'm
gonna buy a big house in a rich and a
wonderful place in Westchester run with
it and I'm going to stand underneath it
while the frame is just up just the
frame this big house with my wife and my
kid and we're going to look at it and
you know what yeah I just I just saw in
it film it's a documentary and also
somewhat of a just regular film
independent film but it's I'm called
driven to stardom yeah story of Tony
Curtis yo mean pretty short very short
strap on your quota so anyways um and
he's his whole theory was similar tears
as a child by 10 age age 10 11 he's I
want to do this I went with I'm born for
this you know this is what I am well be
he told his parents but unlike your
upbringing where was a lot of confidence
it seemed like he had nothing but
obstacles like he had a brother that was
killed and he had lots of tragedies and
his parents were didn't get along and so
no Topher may had a very tough childhood
very tough but he said I'm going to
overcome this and make you guys proud
and I will support you but it sounds
like you didn't have to have all the
obstacle new barriers you had more of a
supportive incredible support offending
you didn't have any job because wife
stars the other half sandal that I had
he was growing up where I grew up which
was a wonderful neighborhood don't get
me wrong but anything could happen at
any time some of my friends went one way
and I went the other way so that was my
obstacle by option was to stay straight
to do the right there but not a lot of
them they lot of them died a lot of them
died from stupid things that just happen
you know whether they're armed robberies
or be to jail but my father was always
don't don't hurt us you have a lot of
talent don't hurt yourself through
family so every time I was about to do
something that I thought was wrong I
just we pulled that and you let your
characters and you're acting fee that
with the bad guy I just pulled back you
know you've got to play this but if you
think about it you know if you think
about how vulnerable life is and that's
why I wrote in the end of Brock still I
said the choices you make will shape
your life forever I mean I don't know
what I'm think my friends pull up at a
car they said hey come on get in and I
was like where you going I said was
caused this yes or no no we just
hot-wired it and I was like you know
yeah no I'm not gonna go you know come
on do you are you a chicken nah you guys
go and may got caught they all got
records no I didn't go nobody got a
record I mean you know it's it's that
close it's like right there it's so full
life is so vulnerable you know the
fascinates me was your interest in
writing always there or is it something
that came along it was always there but
i was too lazy to do anything until I
got fired from this club I'm sure you
know the story I i was working at a
bouncer I ran out of money again I
started working at a bouncer when I was
here and I to make a long story short I
was working there and a guy came over
and said let me and this is high and he
really abusive to me and I said let you
win I said nobody talks to me that were
you're not getting it I'm not letting
doing and this is 1987 and I said you're
not getting it here
he said you're going to be fired in 15
minutes I said really get online
everybody tells me that and it was the
gentleman was 50 Lazar I swifty Lazar
was the biggest agent in the world at
the time and 15 minutes late I was fine
just like you said and I drove home and
I had nobody and I had to another bank
and I just said you know what if they
won't give me a great pot I'll write one
myself so I went to a place I wrote fact
I got five tabs of yellow paper and I
started writing about the killing the
constants and I real brungstun so i have
a question last question okay after how
would you how do you compare the role
that you did in this program particular
movie yeah compared to some of the
others that you've done oh he was like
he was the most paradox of all of the
way he just went he would fly off the
handle you know the only character that
I could put even close there would be
would be filled from hurly-burly you
know he was another one who was just a
mattock manic guy who'd but phil was
much worse than Joe least Joe at times
could be very loving and very nice but
film was just it was pretty much gone
yeah did you find it difficult to at all
no that's why I do what I do you know
where people look how'd you do it I go
that's why i do Michael Jordan can jump
up and duck backwards I can't do that so
yeah that's how I look at it I you know
last question yes um I couldn't quite
understand and mighty fine your
connection to the mom
I know just I felt that you had just
some you know quite a bit of it well he
was a broken wrist richer he was a
Brooklyn Jew who knew these guys and you
grew up in the schemata business you got
to know them that they were involved at
the shot the business constant and what
way though what's gem involved and where
you know so he knew them so that's why
his part is set the buena go to those
guys they do because you know those guys
would you know the money you know on the
outside but when you really need money
then you got to go to them and he said
like you didn't go to them did you and
he did which is a mistake because once
you go to them and you open that can of
worms it's trouble so in your character
work and this is kind of wrong yeah were
you ever involved with those no no as
the Joe fine no not at all but you're
always there with them you know them
especially the smarter business you're
there with them if they're around that
all the time so but you deal them on a
level but when you need them you need
money then give it to you but the juice
on that is big time you know it's a
mistake you get involved I've never been
arrested people look video while but he
was a moment ago and I've been arrested
never been in a mob I grew up with him
but I always stayed away even till today
I see them they hug me I think I kissed
of it but I'm not hanging out with them
because it can only be bad right okay
all right